mein thema heute abend ist die masken
schelte bei kindern die massen kriegt
für die kinder in den schulen wurde
ausgesetzt aber der emotionale druck
steigt und steigt nicht und die
fachredaktion haben eine vielzahl von
briefen nachrichten und anordnung
erreicht und zwar darüber dass die
kinder doch weiter die maske zu tragen
haben lassen sie mich ich habe ein paar
der zuschriften mitgebracht ich konnte
gar nicht alle mitbringen aber ein paar
habe ich mir ausgedruckt lassen sie mich
nur zwei drei sätze daraus vorlesen dass
das hier zum beispiel ist ein brief den
eltern bekommen haben wo drinsteht von
dem direktor geschrieben so bitten wir
sie liebe eltern mit ihren kindern über
das tragen der masten zu sprechen und
sie zum tragen der maske weiterhin
anzuhalten oder auch ich kann es auch
mal rein zeigen hier sieht man auch so
ein schönes schreiben und deutschland
dann somit werden wir alle auch sie und
ihre familien ein gesundes osterfest
feiern sowie gesunde osterferien
verbringen können auch der elternbeirat
unterstützt diesen erhält diesen brief
wird also den kindern eigentlich
vermittelt entweder ihr tragt die maske
also auch den eltern oder ihr habt kein
users das letzte möchte ich hier auch
gerne noch mal zeigen auch wieder genau
dieser aufruf ich finde das furchtbar
man sich auch jetzt hier gerade im bild
eingeblendet bitte freiwillig maske
tragen da stab von einem berufskolleg
meine meinung ist wir müssen den kindern
die angst wieder nehmen wir müssen
kinder wieder kinder sein lassen und ja
vielleicht sollten die kinder sogar
lieber dazu animieren dass sie die maske
absetzen dass sie normal mit ihren
freunden umgehen und ich finde oder ich
sitze hier mit inständig jeden direktor
jeden lehrer und jede schule darüber
nachzudenken ob dieser emotionale druck
richtig ist besonders bei den klein und
ich bin jetzt sehr gespannt auf die
meinung von patricia die auch kinder hat
ja und ich muss sagen das was mich bei
diesem thema am meisten berührt ist dass
wir eine situation schaffen in der
kinder ausgegrenzt werden können und
zwar zum einen weil sie dennoch eine
maske tragen oder zum anderen weil sie
keine maske tragen und dieser situation
möchte ich ehrlich gesagt kinder nicht
aussetzen das heißt wenn wir keine
klaren regeln schaffen schulen im
alleingang für die freiwilligkeit werden
erzeugen wir damit automatisch eine
situation in den kinder ausgerechnet
kinder in die situation kommen sich
rechtfertigen zu müssen und ich glaube
das ist das schwierigste was wir machen
können ich bin selbst sehr vorsichtig
was corona angeht mir geht selbst sowie
vielen eltern ich möchte nicht dass
meine kinder ist bekommen und es macht
mir auch sorge dennoch nach zwei jahren
pandemie glaube ich dass wir uns und
gerade unseren kindern diese freiheit
wieder schuldig sind wir haben gesehen
dass wir immer nur hören wir steuern in
das nächste und wieder es kommt wieder
anders als geplant das heißt irgendwann
müssen wir den punkt kommen würde nur
noch und ganz allein auf menschlichkeit
untereinander setzen und nicht mehr auf
vorsicht und das müssen wir besonders
bei unseren kindern so machen ja und ich
meine wir sehen ja auch also die politik
war ja nun sozusagen offenkundig hat ja
eingesehen dass die verfassungsmäßig
eigentlich keine möglichkeit hat mehr
die harten maßnahmen weiter
durchzusetzen das heißt sie gibt es
freilich gibt es in die
eigenverantwortung der bürgerinnen und
bürger und der eltern und dann tut es
aber doch wieder nicht und schreibt also
wie der berliner senat sieht
zwar keine masken schlicht mehr gegeben
in der schule sie empfehle aber doch
dringend sozusagen die masken trotzdem
zu tragen damit trage ich natürlich
wirklich den den bürgerkrieg also in die
schulen hinein und am ende werde ich ein
problem haben dass im moment die ganze
gesellschaft erfasst also dass nämlich
die ängstlichen sozusagen für alle
bestimmen ich verstehe die ängstlichen
gut ich bin auch der meinung so zu sagen
dass man dieses ganze thema
selbstverständlich sehr ernst nehmen
musst aber wir müssen auch sehen dass
die situation sich ändern also wir haben
inzwischen mit varianten zu tun die
jedenfalls bei kindern also 1000
bruchteilen von prozenten gefährlich
sind und so zogen die meisten kinder
merken nicht mal dass sie infiziert nun
könnte man sagen gut verdienen und noch
wieder mit den großeltern in kontakt
kommen um die großeltern sind zum teil
vier mal geimpft jetzt also muss auch
wirklich sagen wir haben doch alles
menschenmögliche getan insofern lasst
die kinder sich doch von mir aus
tatsächlich anstecken und die meisten
die allermeisten werden ist überhaupt
nicht merken dass die normal miteinander
umgehen und
macht nicht weiterhin diesen druck der
ängstlichen denn angst ist sozusagen
groß und staat und die wird es ist ja
niemandem benommen sich selbst zu
schützen ich finde auch lehrer müssten
natürlich sozusagen dann in der schule
darauf achten dass die dass die kinder
die weiter maske tragen soll weil die
eltern das wollen nicht diskriminiert
geärgert gequält werden aber das kann
man vielleicht hinbekommen aber da kann
man nicht die ganze kinder gesellschaft
die ganze gesellschaft in haft media
sogar noch weiter es gibt auch schulen
die einfach die selbstverpflichtung
verhängt also habe ich auch noch mal
einen brief dass sie alle ausgedrückt
mit der wurde mir also uns auch zuge
spieler steht auch in verantwortliche
haltung und solidarischer
selbstverpflichtung werden wir als xx
schülerinnen hier steht die schüler die
sage jetzt nicht schülerinnen und
kollegium auch ab montag einem
schutzmasken tragen freiwillige
festhalten um uns selbst vor allem aber
die vorerkrankung schülerinnen und
schüler sowie lehrerinnen und lehrer
krank und infektionen zu schützen
sollten die testung an unserer schule
weiterhin möglich sein wenn auch diese
maßnahmen fortgeführt das hat zum
beispiel ein beispiel wo also ist
einfach schon verpflichten von der
schule verhängt und das machen die dann
sozusagen als
solidarischer seitenfenster und ihren
das wurde ja rathaus recht genau
also rein rechtlich dürfen schulen das
jetzt eigentlich gar nicht komplett
verhängen bei privatschulen weiß ich es
nicht wir wissen ja aus der
kinderpsychologie oder aus der forschung
das eigentlich ist für kinder zum
aufwachsen und damit sie auch ganz
stabile persönlichkeiten werden es sehr
sehr wichtig ist dass sie vor allem
durch positive erlebnisse gestärkt
werden und bestärkt werden und das
eigentlich das thema angst und zu sagen
ja gerade gesagt eigentlich genau das
falsch ist und ich stelle mir gerade vor
was in vielen haushalten auch zu hause
eigentlich seit zwei jahren los sein
muss beim thema krone und damit auch
beim thema angst wenn solche maßnahmen
ergriffen werden oder auch wenn solche
briefe von eltern an schulen an
schulleiter geschrieben und geschickt
werden also wie viel angst wird zu hause
dann auch auf kinder projiziert mit
welchen angstgefühlen gehen kinder
möglicherweise oder ganz sicher auch in
die schule in einer zeit in der sie
eigentlich aufblühen sollten und das
gefühl bekommen sollten mensch und liebt
in gewisser weise die welt zu füßen und
wir wachsen da rein und wir können auch
zum besseren beitragen und es passiert
eigentlich genau das gegenteil sie
werden eigentlich aus der welt ein stück
herausgerissen und man sagt ihnen alles
draußen ist ganz ganz schlimm und ganz
böse und du musst dich eigentlich in so
ein kokon ja selbst bringen und ich
einig vor der welt verkriechen das
gegenteil dessen was wir eigentlich
wollen und das bedrückt mich wenn ich
das auch so sehen was du auch sagt und
was man auch hört und liest dann doch
extrem eine angstkultur die an unseren
schulen einzug genommen hat dies
eigentlich so nach meinem empfinden und
mache das nun auch schon mehrere
jahrzehnte durch als schüler und auch
als vater noch nicht gegeben hat und wir
haben ja gerade noch mal neue zahlen von
der britischen schulaufsichtsbehörde
ostedt bekommen die sind einfach
beunruhigend also es ist nicht nur so
dass es eine geschmacksfrage wäre oder
so sondern es schadet auch also zu je
kleiner die kinder sind desto mehr also
verzögert ist auch richtig die
sprachentwicklung ist wird daher auch
hier noch auf mimik gelernt und und dazu
muss man ein ganzes gesicht sehen und
die haben also relativ erschreckende das
sind also qualitative studien
offensichtlich also verschiedene
institutionen aber gründlich befragt und
stelle einfach fest es gibt große
probleme ich weiß nicht wie das ich
glaube der ethikrat sieht das inzwischen
auch etwas kritischer wir sind da noch
am anfang der der aufarbeitung aber es
geht kommen wir deshalb eine geheime max
ist es keine frage es hat auswirkungen
auf die kleinen menschen ich finde diese
studie auch ganz ganz wichtig man darf
ja nicht immer nur von dreien emotionen
her gehen für masten oder gegen machten
sondern sich die wirkung auf die jungen
leute anschauen ich kann mir das
überhaupt nicht vorstellen als so junger
mensch mit so einer ausnahme situation
konfrontiert zu sein kann mich da auch
nicht rein versetzen im kinder aber
dieses das gegenüber nicht sehen nicht
verstehen lächelt er gerade ist er
traurig ist er wütend muss eine ganz
merkwürdige situation sein für die die
das nicht so erahnen können weil sie ja
noch nicht so lange diese sozialen
interaktionen eingeübt haben deshalb
sollte man wirklich solche studien
besonders ernst nehmen und immer stärker
in die debatte einbringen um auf solchen
zahlen grund laden zu orientieren ich
sehe dass selbst bei mir ich habe drei
kinder und zwei davon sind eigentlich in
der tat mit der pandemie aufgewachsen
sind jetzt drei jahre alt und wenn man
die zwillingsmädchen einkaufen spielen
dann holen die sich eine mache und
ziehen eine maske auf um dann so zu tun
als würden sie einkaufen gehen und das
war auf der einen seite süßen auf der
anderen seite hat mich natürlich total
erschreckt weil ich dachte ja natürlich
erkennt gar nicht mehr einkaufen spielen
ohne die maske vor dem gesicht und ich
habe mich auch gefragt was macht es mit
diesen kindern wie bringe ich die
überhaupt an den punkt zu sagen das
machen wir jetzt aber gar nicht mehr das
braucht ihr gar nicht mehr weil das
natürlich bei kleinen dreijährigen schon
so tief drinnen steckt sie kennen es
einfach mich sie waren noch babys es mir
noch ohne maske eingriffen gegangen sind
und ich glaube auch unterschiedlich
total zu dass all diese wirkungen die
völlig noch unabsehbar sind die wir
überhaupt noch nicht fassen können dass
wir uns damit ganz intensiv werden
beschäftigen müssen was machen wir mit
den kindern die angst haben sie angst
haben von der zukunft die angst haben
dass etwas unvorhersehbares kommt und
ich erzähle meine kinder sehr real und
versuche das auch ich will ihnen weder
angst und panik machen noch will ich sie
in bullerbü aufwachsen sehen wir so die
welt nicht ist ich möchte dass wir uns
damit auseinandersetzen und ich glaube
dass das ganz große thema jetzt sein
wird in den nächsten monaten und jahren
wer weiß wie lange diese pandemie uns
auf die ein oder andere art und weise
noch begleitet aber dass wir da unseren
fokus drauf setzen ich bin ja froh dass
die schulen auf haben deswegen bin ich
wahrscheinlich bei der masse erreiche
man denke bevor die schulen wieder zu
machen und man die ganzen kinder wieder
völlig aus nimmt aus diesem gesamten
system und das ging so überraschender
muss schnell das nicht als totalen
tiefpunkte also lud er aber steht erst
als mutter aber ich würde eher sagen
okay das also ich bin ja auch nicht das
hätte niemals passieren wir fertigen die
massen selber dem auch falls wir können
uns nicht einen fehler mit dem nächsten
jahr gut machen ich finde es ehrlich
gesagt wen also halb trauern hier inhalt
noch im hinterkopf hat und ich denke
diese entscheidung haben wir so
leichtfertig jahre schnell geht ja und
bei diesen briefen schreckt auch total
hinter dieses das kind muss die angst
vor spüren dass es andere krank macht
das finde ich eigentlich das schlimmste
dass möglichst wenige ansteckungen in
der letzten woche vor den osterferien
auftreten das heißt jetzt sollen
eigentlich treffer machten damit das
lehrpersonal bloß in die osterferien
fahren die haben auch die haben
ungeimpfte kinder vorgeführt vor der
klasse sozusagen die dann vor der klasse
getestet wurden also sozusagen es
scheint um das die pädagogische begabung
im land durchaus unterschiede bestellt
zu sein also manche und auch um das
engagement ehrlich gesagt und wir wollen
nicht vergessen dass gerade die
lehrerverbände also immer sehr dafür
waren ganz wahnsinnig vorsichtig zu sein
werden glaube ich alle eltern oder die
meisten eltern dies überhaupt
interessiert beobachten konnten das auch
der distanz unterricht für die kinder
nicht besonders gut und nicht besonders
einfach war das heißt also wer wäre
engagierte lehrer hat hat da glück aber
es gibt offensichtlich leute die also
auch gar keinen begriff von
journalistischer demokratische schule
haben da muss ich aber einmal auch
nochmal manchen eltern etwas sagen also
ich finde das passiert man glaube ich
ihm auf jedem elternabend auch sieht man
wie emotional und wir in
unterschiedlichen lagern man sich
befinden überhaupt unter der
elternschaft und ich finde es schon auch
wahnsinn wie viele eltern zu meiner
beobachtungen auf jeden fall ist noch
gibt die an einer zero kurve strategie
festhalten und die für eine sogenannten
durchseuchung die allergrößte panik
haben ich habe eingangs gesagt mir macht
das auch sorge ich möchte nicht dass
meine kinder krone bekommen dennoch ist
mir das wohl meiner kinder und die
menschlichkeit untereinander gerade
jetzt nach zwei jahren pandemie wo wir
ganz klar sehen wir können uns da nicht
in einen panzer abdichten und noch mütze
in so das wird uns alle in irgendeiner
form berühren oder es hat uns schon
berührt ist mir das wichtiger geworden
und ich wundere mich schon darüber wie
viele eltern ist noch gibt die da
wirklich eine ganz ganz extreme position
vertrete für eine extreme angst hier für
herren die fehler der gemacht wurde war
ja dass in den ganzen runden es gab beim
kurz bevor es dann ein bund länder
gipfel gab also bei der bundeskanzlerin
eigentlich ganz ganz viele biologen und
physiker die irgendwelche modelle
modelliert haben gehört wurden was
sicherlich auch sinnvoll war und ist
aber was fehlte waren beispielsweise
kinderärzte oder
jugendpsychiater psychologen die
eigentlich dann aus der praxis hätten
berichten können was macht das
eigentlich mit unseren kindern wenn wir
da an die wohl allen gruppen
beispielsweise die senioren denken dann
ist das absolut richtig aber was macht
das eigentlich mit unseren kindern wenn
wir denen sagen und jetzt bleibt ihr
immer schön drei monate zu hause und
setzt euch an euren computer oder dass
die maske ist natürlich 1 englisch zu
lernen bei einer lehrerin bei einem
lehrer bei dem man den mund nicht sehen
kann stell ich mir relativ schwierig vor
gerade wenn es um das stage
beispielsweise geht also da hat man die
bedürfnisse und belange der kinder
leider gottes über fast anderthalb jahre
komplett ausgeblendet und das ist echt
eine tragödie die ist glaube ich auf
jeden fall aufzuarbeiten gilt leider
sind gewisse verantwortliche personen
dafür nicht mehr in amt und würden fall
kann man auch sagen zum glück nicht mehr
aber wenn es um verantwortung in dem
fall geht dann wäre es glaube ich gut
wenn auch die bundeskanzlerin sich dazu
irgendwann noch mal äußern würde die
ehemalige bundeskanzler muss ich ja
sagen sie ist ja nicht mehr meint wie
könnte frau merkel sich dazu äußern oder
wie könnte sie sich vielleicht auch
entschuldigen und witziges überhaupt zu
sehen nein sie alles was man berlin du
weißt es besser als ich stand sehr sehr
hinter diesem maß also es gibt ja ärzte
die gesagt haben die waren hier auch bei
bild live und die gesagt haben es wäre
toll wenn wir nicht nur theoretiker in
den runden bei der wärme des kanzlerin
hätten sondern wenn wir auch mal
praktiker dort hätten und ich glaube
dass etwas was total gefehlt hat und da
mache ich eigentlich jemandem der in so
eine pandemie startet überhaupt kein
vorwurf aber diese pandemie hat ja nun
länger gedauert und die kritik daran
wurde ja auch lauter und hörbarer und
dann fragt man sich doch warum
eigentlich dann gewisse gewisse ärzte
oder mediziner gruppen eigentlich in
diesen runden nie dabei waren sondern
warum angela merkel eigentlich immer auf
ihr bewährtes personal ich kommunist
erstmal so flapsig gesetzt hat und nie
gesagt hat mensch es gibt ja noch andere
berufsgruppen oder auch andere
gesellschaftsgruppen was ist eigentlich
mit denen wir hören wir die eigentlichen
also dass wählte total und es gab
stellungnahmen also einer großen zahl
von von kinderärztlichen fachverbänden
die aber immer irgendwo im nirwana
letzten endes mehr oder weniger gehört
verhalten wenn sie glück hatten kamen
sie in manchen medien vor in vielen auch
nicht
und ich finde diese frage der
aufarbeitung auch hochinteressant ist
stehen ja im raum der vorschlag zum
beispiel einer enquete kommission zu
machen zu corona und ich finde dass
dringend nötig weil ich finde dass das
parlament auch sozusagen seine eigene
rolle noch mal sehr selbstkritisch
ansehen muss deshalb praktisch die
verantwortung komplett an der tür
abgegeben komplett an die exekutive
abgegeben und gesagt wir unterwerfen uns
den wir tun nicht mal mehr so als ob wir
die epidemische lage von nationaler
tragweite verantwortungsvoll diskutieren
sondern das kann frau kanzlerin mit den
ministerpräsidenten entscheiden und
natürlich könnte eine art kommission
auch noch mal fragen an die ehemalige
kanzlerin formulieren ich fürchte nur
auch da ist nicht viel einsicht ich
finde das hat ideologische züge geradezu
angenommen also dieses team vorsicht
glaubte wirklich im besitz einer höheren
wahrheit und das wurde verteidigt wie
also in den anderen jahrzehnten der
marxismus das war ja auch eine
wissenschaftliche wahrheit und da war
einfach schwer dagegen also dazwischen
zu kommen aber jetzt mit etwas mehr ruhe
ohne zorn aber mit einem kritischen
rückblick wäre es vielleicht besser
möglich